and let me tell you passion is not
something you were born with so many
people are obsessed with becoming
perfect that they never take action you
can become anything you want to be but
life is gonna ask you one simple
question what price are you willing to
pay to get there the motivation watch
the top 10 would believe nation
what's that believe nation it 7 I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack and chew
in today's lessons from a man who went
from growing up in a morbidly obese
family and being dead broke unable to
pay his bills to building a
billion-dollar company and now launch an
immediate brand that he hopes to rival
Disney so he can pull people out of the
matrix
he's tom bill you and here's my take on
his top 10 rules to success volume 8
also if you want to know what tom and
other successful entrepreneurs have to
say about building unstoppable
confidence check out by 250 for
confidence series where every day for
the next 254 days I will send you a
morning video for free to help you build
your confidence the link to join is in
the description below there's a gap
between who people are and what they
tell you they want to accomplish
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one out work talent as Henry Rollins
said I don't have talent so I just get
up earlier the thing that people think
about becoming great about doing the
extraordinary is that it's just meant
for some people and not meant for others
and they spend their time making other
people extraordinary as a way to let
themselves off the hook because if
somebody is just gifted if they were
blessed by God if they were touched by
an angel and they just have something
that you don't and something that you
never will have then it's fine for them
to be great and you to be ordinary but
the reality is it's not how it works
but somehow the cultural narrative has
become one where we celebrate natural
talent that if somebody is graced by God
that if they have something divine about
them that they're somehow better that
it's more beautiful than the scrappy
person who's had to work for everything
they've ever had the guy who simply
acknowledges like Henry Rollins that he
doesn't have more talent than the next
person he's simply willing to work them
he's willing to set the alarm to get up
to do whatever it takes to find his path
to create that skill to outwork talent
to show that by putting in that energy
and that effort there's a magnification
effected as far greater than anything
that can be given to you bestowed upon
you you have to grab it you have to take
it you have to have a level of intensity
in your life to be able to leverage it
and create something amazing
as Warren Buffett said intensity is the
price of excellence if you want to be
great
you've got to cultivate that intensity
you've got to understand it's not about
what you were born with it's not about
what you were getting where you started
or even where you're going it is
entirely about what you plant at the
center of your soul how hard you're
willing to go after something how much
focus you're willing to put in your life
and how often you come back to that
level of intensity for who you want to
be because if you want to meet excellent
you will have to pay a price and that
price is eternal vigilance vigilance
over how you spend your time vigilance
over the demands you make of yourself
vigilance over what you allow yourself
to think and believe and when you get to
the point that you only allow yourself
to think and believe things that move
you towards your goals that every day
the actions you take are things that are
designed to get you there and then you
have the intensity to follow that
through to shape yourself to create a
new version of you capable of doing
something extraordinary then your life
is gonna be what you want but not until
then it's never gonna be anything if you
just make up the people extraordinary
and say I could never do that but the
reality is you could and you're just not
so the thing you have to face right now
is that it is within your grasp you just
have to go after it
rule number two gain mastery and let me
tell you passion is not something you
were born with drives me nuts
everybody thinks they're gonna turn
inside like an archeologist and find
that thing their deepest passion the
thing they always loved hiding inside as
soon as you say it I hope it sounds
ridiculous that you would love something
that much and yet somehow be blind to it
it doesn't work like that
it's like real love you've got to go on
a date first you see somebody you're
interested in you talk to them it sparks
something you spend time you engage and
through that process of engaging with it
maybe if you're lucky it turns into a
fascination but if you really want a
passion you've got to go through the
process of gaining mastery and mastery
is the part of the relationship and
business or in romance where everybody
falls apart because it's where the work
starts it's where you have to do things
long after it stopped being fun rule
number three alter your beliefs now the
process of taking myself from scrounging
my couch cushions to find enough change
to put gas in my car to building a
billion-dollar business was all about
building a set of beliefs now I believe
that the matrix has us all I don't
actually think we live in a simulation
but I think the movie The Matrix is the
perfect metaphor for the human
experience we have all pulled a web of
lies over our own eyes and the web of
lies is what you tell yourself about
what's possible for you and for the
world and once you get that web of lies
over your eyes you simply see it as
reality and you don't understand that
each one of those fundamental beliefs is
alterable but you could choose to
believe something else in fact you don't
even realize that they are beliefs
Einstein as a quote it's one of the most
important quotes in my life the most
important question any man must decide
for himself is whether or not he lives
in a friendly or hostile universe now
what I love about that quote so it's
hiding in it is that it's a decision you
get to choose whether you're living in a
friendly or a hostile universe there's
no objective reality it just is what it
is you're gonna get what you see you're
gonna get what you focus on and you see
what you focus on rule number four don't
chase perfection so many people are
obsessed with becoming perfect that they
never take action and they never learn
to enjoy this moment that may be one of
the greatest tragedies any of us can
face
right now whatever we are however we are
however good we are whatever we've
accomplished that we fail to enjoy this
moment because we have a judgement about
who we are deep down because we haven't
acted in a way that's perfect and I get
it we have this drive it's innate in us
we want to be great it's one of the five
primary human drivers to pursue mastery
to want to master something and truly be
extraordinary I understand the drive but
don't let it corrode you don't ever do
something that eats you alive from the
inside you've got to have a vision of
yourself that allows you to morph and
change and learn from your mistakes but
if you value perfection over learning
then you're never going to become the
person that you'd be capable of becoming
and as Anna Quindlen said the thing that
is really hard and really amazing is
giving up on being perfect and beginning
the work of becoming yourself rule
number five
enjoy the now let me tell you something
that is true beyond measure the struggle
is guaranteed the success is not the
struggle is a guarantee so you better
love what you do on a day-to-day basis
read Eckhart Tolle a is the power of now
the only moment that's real is right now
now follows you so every time you're
doing something if you're standing and
staring and waiting for someone to
finish going to the restroom or whatever
you're standing in line at Disneyland
that is your life that is the sum total
of what you are about in that moment and
life is simply a string of those moments
and so you've got to start asking
yourself am i using those moments wisely
rule number six focus on the beauty
everything around you is incredible if
you're willing to look at it that way
everything around you can be taken for
granted if that's your perspective but
it really is about the frame that you
choose to put around things I mean
simply being alive is already in
same the odds are so stacked against you
not only just being a human but being a
human at this moment in time this moment
in time were breakthroughs in technology
are happening at an unprecedented rate
where breakthroughs in medical science
are happening at an unprecedented rate
where our ability to connect with people
to empathize with people all the way
around the globe all of the changes that
have happened in technology and telecom
and connectivity health everything we're
living in the most miraculous time ever
but you have to look at it that way and
as Joseph Campbell said life is a
wonderful wonderful opera except that it
hurts so the question is do you see it
is the beautiful opera or do you just
pay attention to the pain and at the end
of the day you're gonna get what you
focus on they're both true this is both
the most amazing time that's ever
happened ever in recorded history and
yet real things that are terrifying are
also happening but where you put your
energy where you put your attention
where you put your focus is going to
determine what you see and that is the
most fascinating and the most important
thing you have to understand about the
way that your mind works you get when
you focus on if you focus on the things
that are bad they will become real they
will become exaggerated they will begin
to monopolize your thoughts you'll see
them everywhere it's called the
reticular activating system your mind is
literally designed to pay attention to
the things that you notice once you
notice a certain car you see it
everywhere once you notice a certain dog
you see it everywhere once you hear a
certain name for the first time suddenly
realize that that name has been all
around you this entire time but now that
you're focusing on it now that you're
looking for it it is everywhere so
whatever you look for it's gonna be
everywhere
if you look for the negative he'll be
there before work for the positive it
will overwhelm it rule number seven
become anti fragile and if you guys
haven't read the book anti fragile
buying the seem to leb do in that book
he lays out the difference between
something that is resilient and
something that is truly anti fragile I'm
gonna say somebody that's unstoppable is
truly anti fragile and what anti fragile
is the more you attack it the stronger
it gets there's something that is
resilient or tough it is still defined
by its breaking point the more you go
after it eventually it will break
something that Santi fragile grows with
that and I believe each and every one of
us can build the mindset that is truly
anti fragile there was only one thing
that I have found that it's actually
anti fragile and it looks like this I
was there with my partners they
routinely made me feel stupid all the
time they were older than me they were
more than ten years ahead of me on their
entrepreneurial journey and so I was
just wrong all the time
now up to that point in my life I
actually called myself the king of
remedial jobs up until then I'd only
gone for jobs where I knew I'd be
smarter than the person interviewing me
I knew that at some point during the
interview they were gonna ask that
magical question which made me feel so
good about myself which was why are you
here why are you interviewing for this
job and I lived for that because it made
me feel smart so here I am now not in
that world anymore I'm with guys who are
way ahead of me they're way smarter than
me and I feel dumb all the time and one
day I find myself arguing for this path
and our business because it was my idea
and I knew it was wrong that was a
hilarious thing I knew it was wrong and
yet I was arguing for it like really
passionately and then all of a sudden it
actually worked and they agreed to do it
and I thought oh now what
I've been telling my wife that I'm gonna
make her rich and here I am arguing for
something that just makes me feel good
about myself and I had this moment of
crisis and I asked myself no judgment
what do you really want because if what
you really want is to feel good about
yourself to feel smart to be right to be
worthy if those are the things that you
want then get out of this company
because you're wrong often you're making
mistakes all the time and your partners
are so far ahead of you that they make
you feel stupid so this is like that
doesn't make any sense so if you want to
just go feel good go back to being the
king of remedial jobs be in places where
you're always feeling smart where you're
usually right and live that life but if
on the other hand what you really want
is to actually reach your goals then
you're gonna have to stop worrying about
feeling good about yourself and both of
those felt flawed
everybody needs to feel good about
themselves that that's just the reality
of being a human you've got to find a
way to feel good about yourself but I
really believe everything you do in life
should be in service of your goals and
the moment that you're acting out of the
line note with your goals you might have
a problem with your goal or with your
behavior one of them is gonna have to
change and so I realized in that moment
that I needed to change what I was
building my self-esteem around because I
was building it around being right and
that was wrong so much I was building it
around being smart and I just wasn't
that smart I was building it around
being good and worthy and the fact is
those were just judgements on myself and
so I decided right then and there it's
the one thing in my life that borders on
truly being an epiphany and I realized I
need to change what I build my
self-esteem around and it needs to be
something that I didn't have the word
anti fragile at the time but something
that the more somebody goes after it
the better off I'm going to be the more
it's gonna push me towards my goals and
that thing is and if somebody has a
better ad
I will take it but the only way to build
your ego that is truly anti fragile that
I have found is to be the learner to be
willing to admit when you're wrong to
look at your goal and work backwards and
say is what I'm doing actually moving me
towards my goal or not not does it make
me feel good about myself not am i right
not am i smart is it moving me towards
my goal and if it is then you do it and
if it doesn't then you don't and my life
became that cut-and-dry and you can
literally draw a line in the sand a
demarcation point of my life before that
and my life after that rule number eight
move forward as Kurt Vonnegut one of the
greatest authors in modern times said
when I write I feel like an armless
legless man with a crayon in his mouth
but he still did it and that's the kind
of thing that you're gonna hear from the
greats you're not gonna hear that it was
easy you're not gonna hear that they
felt suave and cool even the greatest of
all time have that awkwardness not
clumsiness they're never quite as good
as they want to be but what I want you
to understand is even though Kurt
Vonnegut said those words he wrote tons
of books that changed people's lives
that changed the landscape of literature
because despite the fact that he felt
awkward and clumsy he kept doing it and
doing it and forcing himself to move
forward to take one step after another
even when the process was not exactly
rewarding
he believed in something he knew that
what he was trying to do would
ultimately get better he knew that if he
wanted to accomplish something great
that he had to push through the
awkwardness and that is the very trick
to getting great you just have to do it
you have to go you have to take that
first step you have to push
you have to drive if to strive every
time to get a little bit better you have
to strive not to fall prey to your own
doubts and insecurities and as Joan Amos
said if you aren't going all the way why
go at all
rule number 9 be willing to pay the
price whatever your skill set is now
whatever your vision of yourself is now
you can change it you can become
anything you want to be but life is
gonna ask you one simple question what
price are you willing to pay to get
there and that's it that's the hard
truth if you're willing to pay the price
and you can become whatever you want you
can become truly capable of the
extraordinary but you've got to go
through the process of building that
skill set you've got to be willing to
stare naked Liat your inadequacies to
understand that you aren't yet the
person that you want to be or need to be
to execute against your goals but that
you can become that person and then
start walking down that path and day by
day brick by brick build the skill set
that you want and rule number ten the
last one before a very special bonus
clip is get started as Haroon 'yeah
noted i always wonder why birds stay in
the same place when they can fly
anywhere on earth and then i ask myself
the same question as mark twain put it
the secret of getting ahead is getting
started and that's where people get
stuck you're literally like the bird you
could fly anywhere you want you can go
anywhere you want to go and look I know
you've got a litany of excuses and all
of them are valid you've got a job you
can't just leave well you don't have a
job and you don't have the money your
family is in one place it's the only
thing that you've ever known you only
speak one language you've never traveled
before you don't have a passport you
can't afford the gas money there are a
thousand
real reasons not to go but the truth is
that none of them matter the truth is if
you want to build something in your life
that you have to remember what Mark
Twain said you have to get started
because at the end of the day that is
literally the only thing that's holding
you back
you're not moving and once you get the
simplicity of that once you understand
that you could act right now you could
say all the excuses you can stop making
them you could stop giving in to them no
matter how valid they are no matter how
real they may seem you can finally
decide that you're going to get a permit
you're going to create that momentum
that you're going to take a step that
you're gonna make the demand that you
create momentum that you get something
done but you find an answer or as
Hannibal said
going to find a way or make one
you have to carve through rock do it
because humans before you
and that's the simple truth that is the
simple is the weak voice in your mind
holding you back and making you a less
version of yourself so I asked you why
doesn't the bird fly wherever it wants
to go because that's all it's known
because that's what's safe because
that's what's comfortable
well because it's a dumb an animal what
do you want to be if this isn't the life
you want to live do something about it
now I've got a really special bonus clip
from Tom on how to adapt that I think
you're gonna really enjoy but before
that it's time for the three-point
landing questions time to move from just
watching another video to actually
taking action in your life or your
business and if you're feeling bold
leave your answers in the comments below
here we go question number one what do
you need to get started on today number
two what price are you willing to pay to
get there and number three what belief
of yours needs to be altered for you to
really achieve your goals
humans lead with belief that may be the
single most important thing to
understand humans lead with belief
meaning you don't do something and then
believe you can do it you won't even
take the first step if you don't believe
that your actions will be rewarded with
results that's why so many people are
paralyzed because they think that
they're not worthy they think they're or
they know they're uneducated they know
that they're not the person that they
need to be in order to accomplish and
the reality is you're probably not the
fact is your skillset has already taken
you as far as it's going to take you so
if you are unsatisfied with where you
are today I have some horrifying news
for you I'll chase it with some good
news but first let's start with the bad
the bad news is your life is an exact
reflection of the choices you've made
that's it it's not circumstance it comes
down to skillset and choices you've
chosen to build a certain skill set
you've chosen to do certain things take
certain risks play certain things safely
whatever the case may be those were all
choices now your life is a reflection of
that what I want you to understand
though the belief the only belief that
you need to have that thing that is
going to allow you to take that first
step is not to believe that you're
capable of what you're trying to build
because we all know you're not I knew
that I wasn't when we start a quest I
knew I wasn't the person that I needed
to be I understood that it just didn't
paralyze me because I believed one thing
and if you take nothing else from what I
say today burn the following statement
into your soul humans are the ultimate
adaptation machine that's it Charles
Darwin is often misquoted as saying that
it's the strongest of the species that
survive he'd never said that what he
actually said was it's not the strongest
of the species that survives nor the
most intelligent but rather the most
adaptive to change we're the apex
predator for a reason because unlike any
other
we have the ability to go in any
direction any direction we want we are
the only species that you can find
anywhere at one point James Cameron was
actually at the bottom of the Marianas
Trench we can thrive anywhere from
Inuits living in the tundra to peoples
that have survived in the desert because
humans adapt that is the fundamental
nature of what we are the most important
word ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple that would be like a
little beacon
[Music]
if you want more tom bill you check at
the top 50 video that i did on him it is
legendary i think you'll enjoyed the
link is right there next to me continue
to believe and i'll see you there don't
get extraordinary go become the best of
whatever it is you want to be but go
become the best of it and see how the
world opens to